tras las elecciones de septiembre que
llevaron a la formación de un nuevo
parlamento alemán y a la elección de
olaf scholz como nuevo canciller el
turno de hoy el turno de este domingo es
para el presidente federal el jefe de
estado el puesto político más importante
del país pero a diferencia de septiembre
esta vez no todos los alemanes están
llamados a las urnas el presidente
federal es elegido por una asamblea muy
numerosa formada tanto por los miembros
actuales del parlamento como por
personas nominadas por cada una de las
diferentes regiones de alemania pueden
ser políticos pero también personas de
la sociedad civil si bien aquí en
alemania muchos consideran que el
presidente tiene un rol más formal o
ceremonial que uno práctico lo cierto es
que su rol ha crecido en importancia en
los últimos años una de sus principales
funciones es la de moderar debates
públicos darle dirección a discusiones
que se están llevando a cabo en la
sociedad
particularmente importante momentos en
que algunos consideran que alemania está
dividida por cuenta de la pandemia de
las restricciones vigentes y de la
posibilidad de una vacunación
obligatoria es probable que fun faltas
time haga el actual presidente que
cuenta además con el apoyo de la mayoría
de los alemanes sea reelegido
cómodamente para un nuevo período de
cinco años